[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de la semaine au
Parlement et avec nous sur ce plateau
nous accueillons Laur Lavalette bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député rassemblement
national du Var et vous allez nous
donner votre regard sur cette semaine
très chargée et dans l'actualité cette
semaine un nouveau 493 à l'Assemblée
nationale faute de majorité sur le
budget 2024 isisabeth borne la première
ministre a dégainé cette arme
constitutionnelle pour passer en force
ce texte et ce avant même qu'il y ait eu
un débat dans l'hémicycle la semaine au
Parlement a été marquée par les
réactions et les hommages après
l'attentat d'aras et la mort du
professeur Dominique Bernard un drame
qui pose une question l'exécutif
avait-il tiré les leçons de l'assassinat
de Samuel pati il y a 3 ans après cette
attaque perpétrée par un étranger fich s
plusieurs voix s'élèvent pour durcir le
projet de loi immigration c'est le cas
de la droite sénatoriale qui débattra du
texte ce début novembre le ministre de
l'Intérieur géraldde Darmanin est ouvert
à des modifications du texte pour lutter
contre la menace
terroriste le débat budgétaire a donc
été écourté à l'Assemblée nationale
elliisabeth borne a eu recours au 493
pour faire passer la partie recette du
budget sans le vote du Parlement c'est
la 13e fois que la première ministre
utilise cette arme constitutionnelle
elle l'a fait avant même le début de
l'examen des article regardez ce
contte-rendu de séance d'Elsa mondingava
il n'y avait aucun suspense quand la
Première ministre est arrivée à
l'Assemblée ce mercredi la parole est à
madame la Première ministre aucun groupe
d'opposition n'est prêt à voter ce
projet de loi de financeces or notre
pays a besoin de ce budget aussi sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement un 493 utilisé à 13
reprises donc mais cette fois en coupe
en cours au débat on est évidemment pas
surpris par le 493 mais il y a quand
même une surprise c'est que le
gouvernement innove même en matière de
493 parce que je crois pas qu'on ait
déclenché un 493 un jour sur un budget
avant même qu'on ait commencé l'examen
des articles mais l'année dernière quand
on avait débattu les oppositions nous
avit dit ça ser rien de toute façon ça
va se terminer par un 493 de toute façon
vous allez pas retenir les amendements
qui onurt été votés voilà on a clarifié
la situation dans ce budget le
gouvernement prévoit de ramener le
déficit à 4,4 % du PIB notamment avec la
fin du bouclier tarifaire sur l'énergie
dans sa copie finale le gouvernement a
retenu l'extension du prêt àau zéro le
dispositif Coluche pour la
défiscalisation des dons en revanche pas
de taxe exceptionnelle ou de crédit
d'impôt pour les résidents despad la
partie dépense sera débattue dans
l'hémicycle à partir du 31 octobre avec
une issue similaire à la première partie
du budget un
493 lor La Valette tous les groupes
d'opposition y compris le votre avaiit
dit qu'il ne voteraient pas ce budget en
tant que tel elliizabeth borne
avait-elle le choix est-ce que vous
n'avez pas aussi votre part de
responsabilité dans ce blocage vous
savez un budget c'est la tradition
comptable de choix politique donc il
vous a pas échappé que nous n'avons pas
euh la même vision de la France que ce
gouvernement donc nous n'aurions
vraisemablement pas voter ce budget
néanmoins euh arriver à faire un 493
sans même faire semblant d'écouter un
peu les oppositions c'est quand même
fort c'est ce qu'ils viennent de faire
on en est donc à notre 13e 493
d'habitude il faisait semblant quand
même de nous écouter parler là ça a été
radical il y a encore plus de brutalité
je pense dans ce 493 néanmoins ce qui
revient tout le temps le fil rouge
j'allais dire de ce gouvernement et je
l'ai vécu toute la semaine dernière
quand j'étais en commission des affaires
sociales où nous travaillant sur le
projet de loit de finance de la sécurité
sociale c'est que ils agissent un peu
comme une secte ils ne prennent même pas
1 % d'amendement qui pourraiit émaner
d'autres groupes politiques il y a quand
même j'allais dire le bon sens n'a pas
forcément de de de frontière politique
et il y a sur tous les ban de
l'Assemblée évidemment de temps en temps
de bonnes idées à prendre et pourtant
sur ce projet de loi de finance le
gouvernement a quand même retenu 300
amendements qui modifient ce budget dont
une quarantaine de l'opposition c'est un
effort de la part de l'exécutif en fait
c'est un effort mais ils n'ont pas le
choix je vous rappelle qu'ils ont perdu
les élections législatives quand même du
19 juin la chance la France a changé les
équilibres politiques vous voyez bien
sont très précaires il ils ont une
majorité tout à fait relative donc ils
vont chercher avec j'allais dire ceux
qui sont macro compatibles voilà un
espèce de
de de donant donnant mais vous savez
nous nous étions très attachés à ce que
la fiscalité qui pesait sur la France
qui travaille migre un peu sur la
fiscalité des grands groupes des
multinationales pour la troisième fois
consécutive ils n'ont pas voulu voter la
taxation des super profits ça nous
paraît quand même bien dommage et c'est
vrai que c'est quand même une c'est
quand même une brutalité d'être à ce
point-là sourd aux députés je vous
rappelle que nous avons tous la même
légitimité nous avons tous été élus dans
des coins de France euh voilà je je
est-ce que à balayer d'un revers de main
cette cette diversité politique ne me
semble pas être la façon de faire je
pense que ces secteurs j'en terminerai
sur les les marchés les gens nous disent
ça les gens sentent et n'aiment pas du
tout le fait que les oppositions soient
à ce pointl mise à l'écart est-ce que
vous pensez que le fait de recourir
aussi souvent aussi franchement à à
l'article 493 de la Constitution
fragilise Elisabeth borne et son
gouvernement oui mais ils sont fragilisé
depuis depuis longtemps je veux dire
tout de suite après la deuxè élection
d'Emmanuel Macron on a bien vu voilà il
n'avait pas sa
majorité ils essayent de traverser les
tempêtes comme ils le peuvent mais je
vois bien en tout cas il y a un désaveux
en désamour de des Français pour ce
gouvernement qu'il juge très brutal mais
voilà Emmanuel Macron nous avait déjà
habitué à de la brutalité souvenez-vous
il voulaient emmerder les Français qui
étaient non vaccinés enfin il y avait
déjà eu des mots quand même très forts
moi je pense qu'effectivement ils ont
une certaine surdité qui peut-être
qu'ils vont même avoir du mal à terminer
ceinquena sur le fond pourquoi les
députés rassemblé national était
véritablement opposé à ce budget qui
prévoyait 16 milliards d'euros
d'économie dans un contexte financier
qui est difficile he pour la France oui
mais parce que en fait il ne font pas
d'économie structurelle donc faut
d'économie structurelle ils finissent
quand même par réhausser les impôts et
nous on peut pas on peut pas se
satisfaire de ça on a une vision encore
une fois très différente il y avait des
économies à faire et on n pas vu dans la
communication du gouvernement une nonce
d'économie sur la bureaucratie sur
l'immigration sur la fraude sur les
cadeaux faits aux multinationales ou
même sur notre contribution à l'Europe
vous voyez on a des points de désaccords
qui sont très marquants et encore une
fois les oppositions ne votent pas le
budget ce serait vous auriez souhaité
qu' qu'il retiennent des amendements
permettant notamment de taxer les
multinationales bien sûr bien sûr mais
bien sûr les super dividendes les super
profit ça nous en avons parlé et c'était
un enfin voilà depuis le début ça fait 3
ans que l'État refuse de le faire voilà
je trouve ça c'est un très mauvais
signal envoyé aux Français qui souffrent
aux Français qui je vous le rappelle
vivent une crise social quand même sans
précédent sur ma circonscription j'ai
encore rencontré la semaine dernière des
des Français me disant ne pas dîner le
soir enfin je veux dire est-ce que c'est
la société dans laquelle on a envie de
faire vivre les Français en tout cas
c'est pas notre choix au rassemblement
national je pense qu'il y avait des
véritables économies à faire le
gouvernement n'en a pas pris le chemin
il continue à faire ses cadeaux aux
grandes multinationales et il continu à
presser j'allais dire cette classe cette
classe moyenne à qui on demande tout et
à qui on ne donne rien lor la Vette
l'actualité a percuté lors du jour à
l'Assemblée après les froids les
questions mardi il y a eu pas moin pas
moins de 10 questions sur l'attentat
d'aras dans l'émicycle de l'Assemblée 3
ans après la décapitation d'un autre
enseignant Samuel pati la quasittalité
des groupes a interpellé le gouvernement
sur le sujet on écoute notamment Marine
Le Pen avec la réponse d'éliisabeth
borne pourquoi ne pas étendre les
expulsions à ceux qui ont commis des
CRIM et des délits graves à leur sortie
de prison islamistes criminels et
délinquants qu'est-ce qui justifie de
garder ces personnes sur notre sol vous
vous lancez dans des polémiques
politiciennes vous jetez des des
anathèmes vous multipliez les mises en
cause alors que le terrorisme frappe et
que la situation internationale est
préoccupante vous refusez ce matin même
explicitement l'unité de notre pays
après cet attentat d'arace plus d'unité
nationale vous faites de la politique
lors la Valette non moi je suis navrée
de la réponse d'Élisabeth borne vous
avez vu en plus elle était plongée dans
sa fiche qui ne correspondait même pas
elle n'a absolument pas répondu aux
questions de Marine Le Pen moi je vais
vous dire ce qui me plonge dans un
désarroi profond c'est que sur ma
circonscription lundi j'étais à
l'hommage à Samuel paatti alors que
Dominique Bernard n'était toujours pas
enterré ça je peux vous dire c'est
inconcevable il devait y avoir un avant
et un après Samuel paatti bah l'après
Samuel paatti s'appelle Dominique
Bernard comment est-ce qu'on a laissé
faire ça comment est-ce que ça a pu aré
reprenez l'audition de de la sœur de
Samuel pati qui vous dit mais mon frère
est mort pour rien on a final finalement
tirer aucune leçon de la décapitation de
Samuel Patis cela fait 3 ans cela me
paraît mettre évidemment les Français en
danger il est temps d'avoir des actes
forts pour le coup on a un projet de loi
qui est tout ficelé que Marine Le Pen
avait proposé l'année dernier enfin au
dernier mandat sur la lutte sur les
idéologies islamistes parce que il faut
évidemment expulser les fichers mais
c'est dans étranger mais c'est dans son
entièreté qu'il faut lutter contre
l'idéologie islamiste on va parler
précisément de la lutte contre le
terrorisme une réaction quand même sur
cette notion d'unité nationale quand
Marine Le Pen critique le gouvernement
seulement quelques jours après la mort
de dobing Bernard est-ce que c'est de la
récupération politique non mais la
récupération politique nous nous sommes
politiques élus par les Français pour
trouver des solutions et pour les
protéger donc union nationale déjà avec
qui est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
l'Union nationale avec les bandes en
face qui n'arrivent même pas à condamner
le Hamas comme comme organisation
terroriste moi je ne peux pas faire une
union nationale avec Madame obono ça
n'est évidemment pas possible ni avec
Mathilde Panau mais moi je pense que les
Français plus qu'une union nationale
attendre des décisions qui les protègent
encore une fois c'est l'intérêt d'être
député j'ai rencontré lundi un couple de
septagéire trop mignons qui m'ont arrêté
dans la rue pour me dire Madame
Lavallette on s'est acheté une bombe
lacrymogène mais ça n'est pas la vie
dans laquelle j'ai envie que les grands
parents de mes enfants vivent ni mes
enfants enfin je veux dire c'est pas
possible à 70 ans de de se sentir
protégé par une petite bombe lacrimogène
c'est au gouvernement et il a échoué de
protéger les Français nous avons des
solutions que nous tenons évidemment à
sa disposition comment faire justement u
Macron dit que dans un état de droit on
ne peut pas totalement éradiquer le
risque terroriste c'est impossible vous
le RN au pouvoir vous l'éradiquer et
comment non mais enfin c'est quand même
extraordinaire que le Président de la
République est quand même censé donner
les grandes orientations qui est censé
protéger les Français vous disent B non
finalement on peut pas faire mais bien
sûr qu'on peut faire la grande
différence c'est qu'en fait ce
gouvernement n'a pas la volonté
politique de faire différemment il y a
plusieurs faisceaux il fallait
souvenez-vous Gérald d'Anin avait montré
les gros bras en disant qu'il allait
fermer les mosquées salafistes mais on
en est où à chaque fois qu'il y en a une
qui a été fermée elle a réouvert par une
décision administrative 3 qu mois après
on en est où de la surveillance vous
avez vu que là ils viennent de nous dire
on va passer au peignef les fichiers au
fsprt étranger enfin vous dites
ENF concevable pour les Français de
penser que ça n'est déjà pas le cas nous
quand on quand on marche dans la rue on
on se dit que les gens qui nous veulent
du mal nous sont évidemment pas là mais
pour ça il fallit ai 43 attentats qui
ont été déjoués en 6 ans cons confiance
qui a un travail qui a été fait que la
DGSI fait évidemment son boulot que les
policiers et les gendarmes qui qui
travaillent dans des conditions très
difficiles font leur travail mais si
vous n'êtes pas soutenu si à côté de ça
on ne met pas en prison ceux qui veulent
at enfin porter atteinte à notre
intégrité nationale mais pour ça encore
fallait-il des prisons encore une
promesse non tenue d'Emmanuel Macron
souvenez-vous premier quinquena il
devait y avoir 15000 places de prison à
la fin du quinena et il y avait à peine
6000 qui sortaient de terre vous voyez
bien que il y a pas cette volonté il
faut une fermeté il faut il faut une
judiciarisation de tout ce qui tourne
autour de ces idéologies islamistes mais
je vais vous dire ça remonte à longtemps
et je pense que les républicains sont
évidemment aussi fautifs le rapport
auain de 2004 qui parlait de la
pénétration de l'idéologie islamisme à
l'école islamiste à l'école a été mis
sous le tapis par François Fillon qui à
l'époque était ministre de l'éducation
nationale alors que déjà il il alertait
déjà en disant voilà il y a des enfants
qui ne rentrent pas dans une salle de
classe parce que le mobilier est rouge
et que le rouge c'est haram il y a des
salles de classe de des filles entières
qui sont allergiques au clore en fait
pour juste pas aller à la piscine et
montrer leur corps enfin ça fait
longtemps qu'on le sait ça fait
longtemps que le rassemblement national
en parle rien n'est fait je je crains
qu'il faillit attendre 2027 Gérard
Darmanin assure que son projet de loi
immigration qui sera soumis au au
Parlement et qui facilite l'expulsion
des étrangers dangereux aurait permis
d'éviter cet attentat d'aras est-ce que
vous allez voter ce texte non mais ce
qui aurait évité l'attentat d'aras c'est
que cette personne là soit pas sur sur
notre sol ce qui aurait évité le meurtre
de la petite Lola c'est que la personne
qui avait une obligation de quitter le
territoire français ne soit plus sur
notre sol Gérald amanin a le taux
d'qtf d'obligation de quitter le
territoire français le plus bas de
l'histoire donc il peut pas nous dire
après j'ai un projet de loi si déjà il
ne fait pas appliquer la loi qui est là
et puis en même temps ils soutiennent le
PCT d'immigration au niveau européen qui
va obliger la France sous peine d'amende
de 20000 € par migrants non accueilliis
de répartir les migrants dans les
campagnes donc en fait je dis à
géraldanin il faut de la cohérence il
faut protéger les Français c'est pas
donner un peu d'un côté si de l'autre
côté vous ouvrez tout et puis vous avez
vu juste après la Belgique Gérald
armanin dit on va renforcer on va
renforcer les les contrôles à la
frontière donc ça veut quand même
direattent qui est juste après ouais ça
veut quand même dire que finalement ce
concept d'ésué de frontière pourrait
avoir aussi son intérêt je pense qu'on a
déjà en France de quoi protéger les
Français ce qui manque c'est la volonté
politique et ben justement lors la
Valette on va parler du fond de ce
projet de loi immigration qui sera
discuté au Sénat début novembre les
sénateurs les républicains veulent
durcir le projet de loi du gouvernement
mais ils ont encore quelques désaccords
avec leur alliés centristes Cécile Sixou
vous explique les enjeux de ce débat le
texte immigration un casse-tête pour
géralde Darmanin avant même son examen
au Parlement le ministre le sait il ne
pourra pas compter sur les LR dont il a
besoin pour avoir une majorité s'il ne
retire pas l'article 3 celui-ci prévoit
de régulariser les sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension des articles sur
lequels nous ne lâcherons pas c'est la
régularisation par le travail vous le
savez ça c'est des lignes rouges sur
lesqueles nous ne lâcherons pas une
ligne rouge à droite qui agace
particulièrement les centristes les
partenaires DLR au Sénat sont favorables
à cette mesure il est important pour un
seul article qui devient totéique et qui
mérite pas autant
d'ignominie qu'on puisse trouver une
solution très sincèrement après ce qui
s'est passé à haras après ce qui s'est
passé à Bruxelles quand on voit la
difficulté au ProcheOrient
s'arrêter sur un article comme celui-là
c'est vraiment pas au niveau de la
situation trouver un accord pourrait
vouloir dire sortir la mesure du texte
mais ce scénario c'est le groupe
Renaissance à l'assemblée qui le refuse
s'il ne l'est pas au Sénat nous
leinttroduiront à l'Assemblée nationale
là où il faut être très clair là faut
c'est qu'il faut juger il faut juger les
étrangers pour ce qu'ils font et pas
pour ce qu'ils sont 100 point de
convergence sur cet article le ministre
cherche à séduire autrement les LR il le
dégage sur le côté fermeté du texte et
se dit prêt à revoir sa copie s'il y a
des propositions supplémentaires d'où
qu'il viennent qui permettront à
n'importe quel moment et conformément à
ce que le gouvernement essaie de faire
depuis le début de l'élection du
Président de la République c'est-à-dire
avoir la
fermeté contre tous ceux qui veulent
toucher les valeurs françaises je
donnerai un avis favorable mais pas sûr
que les efforts de géralde Darmanin ne
suffisent les groupes LR du Sénat et de
de l'Assemblée ont inscrit une
proposition de loi concurrente dans leur
niche parlementaire les 7 et 12 décembre
prochains elle propose entre autres de
déroger au droit international sur les
questions migratoires ou encore
d'élargir le référendum à la politique
d'immigration lors la Valette les
sénateurs les républicains veulent donc
durcir ce projet de loi immigration pour
lever encore davantage de frein aux
décisions d'expulsion Géraldo daranin y
est favorable comment les députés RN
pourraient ne pas voter ce texte qui va
être durci en fait gerérald amanin est
dans une position très difficile il a au
sein même de sa majorité vous prenez
Caroline janvier qui disait hier chez
vos confrères que elle ne pourrait pas
voter ce texte et
que l'assassin aurait du professeur
aurait pu être expulsé alors que lui dit
dit l'inverse et en même temps vous avez
Sacha Houlier député aussi de la
majorité qui pose chez vos contrefrères
à la une avec des des députés de gauche
en disant non il faut absolument la
régularisation des clandestins donc vous
voyez bien à quel point c'est difficile
nous on pense que ce texte ne va pas
assez loin on attend de voir évidemment
ce qui va arriver sur nos sur nos
petites tablettes mais mais encore une
fois c'est cette dichotomie entre ce qui
va venir chez nous et ce qu'ils vont
faire au niveau européen il faut
absolument que la France reprenne la
maîtrise de de savoir qui rentre et qui
sort de son pays on narrive pas en
France en comme ça il y a des droits il
y a des des devoirs on est
vraisemblablement pas sur la même
longueur d'onde évidemment avec Gérald
haranin parce que là il dit qu'il veut
durcir mais ça fait 6 ans qu'ils sont au
pouvoir pourquoi n'ontils ant pouro n'il
pas échappé voyez ce que je veux dire
pourquo est-ce que tous ces gensl ét
encore sur notre alors qu'il ne l'aurent
pas d et je rappelle ce sont eux qui
sont au manettes ça ne sont pas alors il
y a un volet fermeté dont vous parlez
mais il y a aussi ce fameuse article 3
qui permet de régulariser dans les
métiers en tenstion si le gouvernement
retirait cet article 3 vous le voter
c'est pas suffisant c'est pas suffisant
parce que ça ne va pas assez loin alors
par contre il faut bien oui oui il faut
bien expliquer aux Français ce que c'est
he cet article 3 c'est une nouvelle
filière d'immigration sous prétexte que
l'on ait besoin de main d'œuvre
notamment dans les mitiés de la
restauration alors qu'il y a sûrement
d'autres façons de faire notamment
d'augmenter les salaires qui permettrait
à Fr les travailleurs sans papier dans
les métion voà exactement et et en fait
ça ça va continuer à faire à faire
baisser les salaires à à la baisse et
surtout c'est une nouvelle filière
d'immigration alors que nous n'en
pouvons déjà plus et que ce gouvernement
a des records en matière d'immigration
légale et les Français ont bien compris
toute la toute la tout tout le lien si
vous voulez entre cette immigration
dérégulée et l'insécurité quand vous
voyez que 75 % des mineurs qui sont
déférés au parquet de Paris sont des
mineurs d'origine enfin étranger ça
n'est pas possible de les garder sur
notre et ça c'est au moment où je vous
parle Gérald Amam aurait déjà pu faire
en sorte que ça ne soit pas le cas donc
l La Valette je repose un petit peu ma
question je la reformule si ce texte est
durci c'est-à-dire s'il n'y a plus cet
article 3 et si les freins aux décisions
d'expulsion sont levés c'est ce que veut
faire la droite sénatoriale et Géral
Darmanin n'est pas fermé est-ce que le
RN pourrait voter ce texte alors c'est
un nom de principe non c'est pas un nom
de principe on va attendre de voir comme
on a fait sur tous les textes mais je
pense qu'en matière immigration ça n'ira
pas assez loin il faut que nous
reprenions au niveau national la
maîtrise de nos flux migratoires c'est
ce qu'attendent les Français et dans la
mesure où ça reste chapauté quand même
encore par l'Europe je ve dire tout ce
que vous pourrez vous pourrez mouliner
des petits bras en bas si à côté de ça
on continue à vous demander de répartir
des migrants sur le sol français ça ne
sera pas possible il faut et Marine Le
Pen avait au moment de la présidentielle
un référendum qui était enfin une
proposition de loi une proposition de
loi qu'elle voulait proposer à
référendum qui faisait 17 pages que les
Français peuvent encore trouver sur le
site du rassemblement national où elle
explique comment il faut qu'on arrive à
constitutionnaliser ça sur le fait que
ce soit les Français qui est la maîtrise
des fluxs migratoires ça fait 40 ans que
cette politique leur est confisquée et
justement la droite sénatoriale fait une
proposition loi constitutionnelle pour
permettre ce référendom sur
l'immigration pour déroger aussi à
certaines règles européennes ce texte
constitutionnel il va être débattu en
décembre au Sénat 11 décembre à
l'Assemblée aussi voilà est-ce que les
députés Rennes pourrai le voter he ça
correspond à leur proposition on va voir
comment ça va arriver et d'ailleurs
c'est assez marrant parce que je vous
rappelle que pendant l'entre de Tours
les républicains disaient ah non mais ça
c'est pas possible on peut pas faire ça
ce que proposait Marine Le Pen alors
qu'ils vont proposer quasiment la même
chose après je me souviens quand même
que les républicains par exemple ne
voulaient pas mettre fin au droit du du
du sol et nous ça nous paraît quand même
fondamental c'est pas parce que vous
naissez en France que vous êtes français
pour ça il faut j'allais dire montrer
une certaine appétence à être français
parler français vouloir adhérer aux
valeurs typiquement vous voyez le droit
du sol pourrait nous empêcher de voter
ce texte l'absence du droit du sol par
pourrait nous empêcher de voter ce texte
ce texte prévoit l'expulsion à
l'étranger en situation irrégulière qui
représente une menace grave pour l'ordre
public est-ce que cela signifie quand on
a des preuves des écoutes avant même la
condamnation en justice il faut pouvoir
expulser non mais bien sûr on ne peut
pas garder sur notre sol des gens qui
sont des bombes humaines quand vous
savez qu'un étranger qui est sur notre
sol a des et a une fiche pour une la
radicalisation mais oui c'est ça
s'appelle la vertu de prudence et c'est
ça qui permet de protéger son peuple
qu'est-ce qu'on demande à dirigeants on
demande à des dirigeants de pouvoir
retrouver notre sécurité qui est la
première
déliit écoutez quand on a des preuves
oui mais quand on a des preuve tangible
qu' a une radicalisation qu'ils en
veulent à l'état français qui a une une
apologie du terrorisme par exemple vous
savez que les réseaux sociaux maintenant
on arrive évidemment à retracer le le
profil il faut protéger les Français si
ça doit en passer par là il faut
expulser tous ceux
qui veulent porter atteinte à notre pays
on ne peut plus si vous voulez pourfin
souvenez-vous il y a quand même eu le
Bataclan il y a eu il y a eu Nice où les
Français ont quand même allé un 14
juillet 80 d'entre eux ne sont pas
revenus parce qu'ils ont été écrasé par
un un radicalisé enfin on peut plus
vivre ça ça n'est pas possible en tout
cas ça n'est pas la société dans
laquelle je veux que ni mes parents ni
mes enfants vivent on parlait de 493 sur
le budget tout à l'heure en cas
d'utilisation du 493 sur ce texte
immigration de géralde de daranin est-ce
que vous pensez qu'une motion de censure
pourrait la faire tomber le gouvernement
non mais moi je pense que déjà le 493
enfin ça me paraîtrait encore d'une
brutalité inoui oui ça voudrait dire
qu'on ne discute plus de rien enfin vous
voyez il y a un vrai souci je pense que
il est temps que ce que l'immigration
arrive sur la table gouvernementexte
drite d'accord enfin c'est un peu
l'arlaisienne ça fait déjà depuis qu'on
est élu on nous dit que le texte
immigration va arriver sur la table et
vous voyez bien ça fait déjà un peu plus
d'un an et demi et il n'arrive jamais
donc on voit bien qu'ils n'ont pas les
coups des
Franches la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale souhaite un vote du
parlementant ou oui je sais bien mais
parce que je pense qu'il y a il y a
urgence mais c'est pas faute de dire
qu'il y a urgence pour le coup
j'appartiens à une famille politique qui
qui alerte depuis bien longtemps que
voilà que l'idéologie islamiste fait des
ravages dans notre pays donc il faut
prendre la mesure il faut le faire je
suis pas sûr que le gouvernement là soit
le mieux placé vous voyez je pense que
quand on a le le bilan de de Gérald
armanin dans une démocratie ordinaire on
aurait peut-être déjà démissionné vous
voyez quand vous avez un Dominique
Bernard après un Samuel pati et vous
étiez déjà au commande je pense que
c'est un problème ouais dernière
question sur ce thème de l'immigration
lors la valallette une partie des
terroristes qui ont frappé notre pays
sont étranger mais est-ce que cela
signifie pour vous qu'une majorité des
étrangers représente une menace pour
notre pays non mais rien à voir enfin je
veux dire c'est évidemment au cas par
cas je tous les étrangers sont pas
terroristes heureusement par contre ce
qu'il faut évidemment mettre enquoir
tant limiter l'immigration mais non mais
c'est pas c'est pas tant limité déjà
tant limité l'immigration parce que
quand vous avez 100 millions de pauvres
et 6 millions de chômeurs globalement
vous vous dites qu'il y a déjà
suffisamment de monde sur votre sol et
que vous devez en en priorité vous
occuper du peuple français et puis y a
des emplois qui sont pas question oui
mais il y a un problème de des salaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
voulions rassemblement national
augmenter de 10 % tous les salaires dans
une entreprise jusqu'à TR fois le SMIC
avec une exonération de charge il faut
rendre aussi le travail le travail
attractif si vous voulez dans la
mandature précédente il y a eu une
mission un rapport qui a été fait par
des collègues députés pas du tout de ma
de mon bord politique où il parlait de
l'insécurité qui montait quand il y
avait des MNA sur le sur le territoire
il y a un lien évident des murs il y a
un lien évident entre l'insécurité et
l'immigration il est de de le régler
vous savez ces gens-là arrivent aussi
sur notre sol avec une culture qui n'est
pas la nôtre on le voit bien si vous
avez des enfants vous devez bien le
vivre aussi au
quotidien ça n'est plus possible ça
n'est plus tolérable les Français
surtout n'en veulent plus alors la
Valette on va finir par une polémique
qui concerne votre famille politique
votre collègue le député rassemblement
national de Mosel Laurent jacobelli a
été filmé en train d'insulter le député
renaissance de moiselle belkir beladad
il l'a traité je cite de rakaille il va
bien le Hamas lui a-t-il demandé en
référence au fait qu'il avait déposé des
fleurs avec sa collègue député insoumise
demoiselle Charlotte l duuc est-ce que
vous condamnez les propos de votre
collègue ou est-ce que vous les minimis
non mais c'est c'est polémiqu
complètement stérile moi je connais bien
Laurent jacobelli je peux vous dire que
c'est un député qui est très aimé en
Moselle là vous prenez un tout petit
bout d'une vidéo où ils ont eu un
échange une altercation parce que là on
ne voit pas ce que lui a dit mon autre
collègue député mais il s'est pas pointé
en lui disant ça comme ça il y a eu un
échange qui était houleux il se trouve
que la vidéo ne montre que le moment où
Laurent jacobelli parle c'est paraîêtre
une malhonnêteté intellectuelle pas
possible ça a été une tentative je pense
de de voilà de de de diversion ou de
vouloir jeter le propre sur Laurent qui
est un un formidable député qui
travaille beaucoup qui est d'une
gentillesse connue de tous donc non
c'est une une polémique montée trit son
collègue de racaille c'est normal non
mais c'est c'est encore une fois
j'aimerais bien si vous voulez on peut
regarder l'extrait en entier mais ça il
y a déjà une agressivité terrible de
l'autrre députés en en avant je vous
remercie Laur Lavallette d'avoir été
notre invité et nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec un autre invité
ciao
[Musique]